président centriste de la commission de
la culture Tam vient de le dire Gérard
Larchet a annoncé ce matin que vous
aviez saisi l'arcom en fait le président
du Sénat il dénonce des propos éloignés
de la mission du service public d'évolué
à Radio France notamment celle relative
au respect de la personne humaine à sa
dignité ainsi qu'à la promotion des
valeurs d'une culture et d'un civisme
partagé c'est ça la raison qui fait que
vous avez saisi l'arcom oui France
interne n'est pas n'importe quelle
chaîne c'est une chaîne du service
public comme vous l'avez rappelé qui est
liée à l'état par un cahier des charges
et et dans ce cahier des charges il y a
très clairement ce que vous venez de
dire et qu' rappelé le président Larchet
ce matin le respect et la dignité de la
personne humaine qui font qui figurent à
l'article 5 du cahier des charges et la
phrase de Guillaume murriis et de ce
point de vue-là pour nous plus que
borderline la ligne a été franchie c'est
ça mais le président du Sénat qui
rappelle aussi l'importance de la
liberté d'expression aussi la liberté de
caricaturer cé important après est ce
qui s'est passé à Charli Hebdo vous
reconnaissez pas qu'il était dans sa
liberté d'expression Guillaume muris la
limite est toujours extrêmement complexe
et moi je reconnais un droit à l'erreur
on peut se tromper le le problème avec
guillaumeuris c'est plus que lui ne
s'est pas excusé tout le monde peut
comprendre que dans l'exercice un peu
tangent de l'humour où on cherche
justement les limites et on essaie
d'exprimer parfois des choses en
dépassant ces limites il faut aussi
reconnaître parfois qu'on peut se
tromper dans une blague ce qu'il n'a pas
fait
y